nachgefragt in der hauptstadt bei
barbara junge von der taz größe ganz
herzlich gibt man hätte jetzt geht es
endlich los heiße phase vier wochen
knapp vier wochen und die union kommt in
gang armin laschet auch genügend
naja also die linkspartei nummer die
jetzt kommt das ist doch also
tatsächlich ein totes pferd so sehe ich
das
olaf scholz hat relativ deutlich gemacht
welche präferenzen hat und werde die
linkspartei einschätzt insbesondere in
bezug auf die nato und also es gibt eine
wechselstimmung das würde ich auch sagen
vielleicht auch für ein etwas linkes
bündnis aber doch nicht viel
linksbündnis damit denke ich wird armin
laschet und wird die union wirklich
nicht in aufschwung schaffen und armin
laschet hatte gestern seinen 15 punkte
programm zum klima zur klimapolitik
vorgestellt auch darin sehe ich nicht so
den ganz richtigen aufbau hat zwar
einerseits wirklich auch kompetente
leute an seine seite gestellt wie zum
beispiel andreas jung aber andererseits
ist es also vier wochen vor der wahl
sechs jahre nach den pariser klima
geschlossen doch ein bisschen spät das
zentrale thema der zeit zu erkennen und
die union hat klimaschutz
verhindert in den letzten jahren und
eine sache nach und das war auch beim
trial ganz klar zu sehen armin laschet
es nicht diesen zentralen widerspruch
aufzulösen dass es radikalen klimaschutz
der ist notwendig nicht ohne zumutungen
gibt da sehe ich wirklich keine stärke
und wenn ich das noch anschließen darf
im trial kam auch nicht zum ausdruck
dass da noch irgendwie kraft von armin
laschet ausgeht wer hatte denn kraft im
dreh war das dann vielleicht nach scholz
also nochmal zu armin laschet zurück er
war im trial nicht stark und wenn man
mit ihm spricht das wichtig für den denn
wenn man die gespräche mit bekommt und
ich habe in letzter zeit zumindest
gespräche
mit tschuldigung diese gespräche erlebt
da kommt auch kein geheimplan und da
kommt dann olaf scholz ins spiel ein
geheimplan hat er auch nicht aber er
macht merkel er macht souverän er macht
er lässt alles an sich abperlen also es
fehlt nur noch dass er plakatiert sie
kennen mich wie es merkel gemacht hat
und offenkundig liegt darin eine gewisse
stärke das hat zumindest die auf die
auswertung des tri ace
gezeigt kann man die dritte im bunde
dann zumindest noch frau baerbock
annalena baerbock kann sie merkel
anna lena berger kann nicht merken also
sie ist nach dieser diesem
plagiatsaffären würde ich es nennen und
der lebenslauf politur erstmal ein
bisschen verschwunden der glanz war
wechsel ist jetzt wieder zurück denke
sie hat diesen schreck und den schock
überwunden und hatte einen starken
auftritt sie hat er auch das halten
starken auftritt weil sie die einzige
ist die nicht regiert die glaubhaft für
so ein wechsel stehen kann und die
glaubhaft natürlich für einen
engagierten klimaschutz mit sozialen
bedingungen stehen kann aber also ich
würde sagen 17 18 prozent auch wenn die
umfragen heute etwas runter gehen sind
für die grünen auf jeden fall drin aber
das kanzleramt ist doch ziemlich weit
weg gerückt es geht ja ich meine wir
müssen uns mal sagen wie es ist es geht
um die merkel nachfolger es geht nicht
nur einfach darum bundeskanzler zu
werden sondern das ist ja nicht nur
fußstapfen die man da beschreiben müsste
es ist eine nationale und internationale
persönlichkeit die jetzt ersetzt werden
muss da gibt's schon fast fragezeichen
im ausland wie wollt ihr das machen hier
deutschen wer soll das denn können dann
schaut man auch die drei kandidaten und
dann sind drei fragezeichen oder gibt es
für sie kein fragezeichen na also der
blick von außen das auf jeden fall
verwunderung dabei verwunderung
natürlich auch
wie die nachfolge von merkel ausgefüllt
werden kann als man es geht um eines der
reichsten länder der welt tatsächlich
und dafür sieht man schon gewissen
schlingerkurs hier im wahlkampf und aber
das zählte auch zu dieser veränderung es
ist klar dass es das was neues kommen
wird sind vier bis fünf
koalitionsoptionen im moment das
verunsichert auch und dann kommt noch
etwas dazu verwunderung darüber dass die
charismatischen politiker nicht auf dem
wahlzettel stehen da haben sie ein
schönes stichwort wahrscheinlich sind
die ganzen parteizentralen schon so
nervös und sie werden noch nervöser wenn
sich dann noch so zweite spielorte oder
schatten spielorte auf den bühnen eignen
ich sage nur so da und hab ich
ja dieses duell und auch noch kurz vor
dem trial war durchaus bemerkenswert
aber da haben die beiden sehr
unterschiedliche interessen da drin herr
söder steht jetzt nicht besonders stark
an asche seite
anders ist es natürlich bei robert
habeck da muss ich auch eine art auch
positionieren für die nächste regierung
möglicherweise und um natürlich eine
zweite starke kraft für die grünen
darzustellen aber für
annalena baerbock und armin laschet ist
es natürlich nicht besonders einfach so
unter dem schatten der ja der der
vielleicht stärksten nicht kandidaten
die wir jemals hatten zu arbeiten da
stelle ich mir auch anstrengend vor wenn
man immer weiß im hintergrund tut sich
helfen lassen man weiß nicht was also zu
sagen haben bereitet sich quasi vor und
bringt sich in position für die arbeit
in einer regierung die angestrebt wird
als vielleicht aus minister was weiß ich
leider
ist jetzt schon klar der wenig ist
geht's dem vielleicht schon und
vielleicht hab ich schon um die nächste
bundestagswahl
naja bei harnik ist es schon ja auch
durchaus bekannt der welt durchaus auch
gerne der kandidat geworden insofern ist
anzunehmen dass er in dieser regierung
auch eine position möchte und
insbesondere da ein starker zweiter
kandidat ist auch haben könnte bei söder
also solche äußerungen wie ein starker
auftritt über armin laschet beim tri l
sind ja eher eine demütigung als als
dass es eine stärkung wäre das scheint
schon eher auf für die nächste wahl in
vier jahren einzuspielen da ist richtig
was los in der hauptstadt sind gespannt
wie es in den nächsten wochen weitergeht
für heute sage ich ganz herzlich
dankeschön barbara junge dank und grüße